we're going to turn now to Ukraine where
yet another round of suicide drone
attacks has brought Terror to the people
of Kiev and other cities in Ukraine it
is the latest Russian escalation of a
war which has not been going well on the
battlefield for the man who started it
that would be of course Vladimir Putin
Holly Williams has our story
this morning and they seem to be
targeting the energy and water supply
including a power plant in Kiev ahead of
Ukraine's harsh winter
yesterday's attack on Ukraine's Capital
by a swarm of so-called suicide drones
Kamikaze weapons packed with deadly
explosives
that detonate on impact Ukraine says
four people were killed in Kiev one of
them was Victoria zamchenko who was
reportedly six months pregnant with her
first child
kiev's mayor Vitali Klitschko called
Russia a terrorist State I feel a lot of
people civilians I'm guilty people and
that way it's where a terror attack
Ukraine claims that Russia's ordered
nearly two and a half thousand suicide
drones from Iran they reportedly cost
around twenty thousand dollars each a
fraction of the price tag for a guided
missile Iran denies that it's arming
Russia in Ukraine
the world must stop this terrorist said
Ukraine's president last night for
months his country's been asking the
West for better air defense systems in
Russia last night just over the border
from Ukraine a fighter jet plowed into a
residential building the fiery aftermath
killed 13 people according to State
media Russian authorities say they're
investigating
the only good news is a prisoner swap
the two sides exchanged over 200
detainees yesterday including 108
Ukrainian women mostly soldiers who were
now free
many of Ukraine cities including Kiev
had been relatively calm for months but
Russia's use of suicide drones small and
cheap could have a significant impact on
the course of this war Tony
Holly Williams forest in Ukraine Holly
thank you very much